what happens when we outgrow the story
of ourselves
you know how some people say don't get
stuck in your own story which is
actually a very powerful thing
because we can wear our stories as like
this badge to the world
whether they're good or bad what happens
when we start to outgrow
those stories i believe when you start
to outgrow your stories
you start to have like an existential
crisis
[Laughter]
i i'm joking but that means that there's
a
there's a big shift in your life that's
happening and that's a great thing
right um
did you feel that you had outgrown your
story you were a journalist
and you wanted to change it and this was
your your new
endeavor your new career with script
writing
you know i
i think that i don't know i just was
tired of what i was doing so i was
probably running from
and trying to run toward for the first
time in my life something i wanted to do
and i was too much of a chicken to be a
full rider just jump off the cliff
entirely
so i said to myself in small increments
i can learn to do these pitches
okay that's safe that's some writing and
that's some business and then i
crab walked a little bit further over
and did speech writing and then
found how rich it is and how beautiful
it is and then my next step is to go
further beyond that and i'm ready
because my speakers have given me so
much
and taught me so much but in terms of
in terms of letting go of old stories
amy's talk again is really perfect
because in that middle part
where we wrote you know i had to let go
of the old amy so i could embrace the
new
that was so profoundly powerful for her
for me
for the audience for her becoming teary
because she was literally pronouncing
that she was letting
go and you don't you would think well
you lost your legs
you move on right but loss is a tricky
thing
and loss takes time it's not when you
lose someone you love
or something you love that was you hoped
was going to be forever um
there are a lot of
little imperceptible layers that have to
be let go
and that speech for amy was
a lot of that that she hadn't really
addressed and that's what we
sat down and talked very intimately
about right
um and so that's how we got to that
transition
and it was very liberating for her
and that's the power of story
when we really really start to get in
alignment
with what it is we're saying i ask my
speakers what's your motivation for
saying that i ask myself
because many times i'll throw out old
stories and i'll be like and you feel it
in your body that didn't feel right why
did i say that
that doesn't fit me anymore stop saying
that move on
right but then what
do i replace it with and what was my
motivation for saying it in
the past asking ourselves what's our
motivation
for saying anything prevents a lot of
missteps and mishaps
in the world with ourselves and with the
people around us
and that starts to get us on a better
path because our
our power is our story what are we
telling ourselves internally
externally to the world because what we
feel is what
we attract is what we are it's just a
mirror
of us right and so most of the time
we're blah blah blah blah just talking
and not understanding
that our words have weight there's a
in japanese and i'm probably going to
get it wrong but it's called i believe
it's called
kotodamo domo kotodomo i think it is
and it they say it's spirit words
that words have spirit and
they do because i've sat with those
words and i've weighed and measured them
and i can see when they hit the mark
and when people sit in the audience and
they're i can feel
them feeling the words
so as i say to my speakers
if you don't feel the words as the
speaker
the audience won't either if you think
those words
nobody cares you can't wrap your arms
around uh logic
you can only wrap your arms around
love and emotion that's all there is and
we're starved for it as
culture and as as the human race
will really starve for that connection
and to feel those feelings and it's our
job
as artists to really dig down
deep and to go there to do the work
that others can't do because their lives
are so hectic
or so business oriented or whatever
there's a disconnect between heart and
head
and so it's it's really
us leading the way to let people know
that they can do it too
it's excellent it reminds me of um did
you listen to dolph lundgren's
ted talk no i didn't oh okay so he
talked about
you know he has a successful career but
there was still a part of him that was
sort of i think he said frozen inside
and it was just
you wouldn't expect somebody that you
know was just strapping you know
big guy handsome to have you know to be
able to
to admit some of these things that was
really touching
and you know we talked about similar
things and so
um it was just interesting because it
was talking about you know being
successful but still feeling
old feelings inside not not a reversal
of something happening so it was just
fascinating i love that i love that
because i think that
we're a society of addiction because
the minute we feel discomfort we
do something go to our phone we have a
drink
go back to work right and so we
the key in life to changing our lives
changing our stories
is to be able to sit with that
discomfort to breathe into it and say
why do i feel uncomfortable at this
moment what is that
and and it might be the way we're
telling our story
it might be the way we're relating to
the world and does that fit us anymore
and this isn't an easy thing this is a
practice
right this is a form of meditation in a
sense
storytelling it isn't a form it is it is
meditation because the more you can be
present in your in your body and
feeling your feelings um and then
sharing those feelings will connect with
each other
and people are starved for that you know
that's why
i'm hired again and again and again is
because i really do care
and i really do want to hear people's
stories because
their stories help me with my stories
and we share you know this beautiful
like we feed each other and we build
upon
that positive energy even when we're
telling stories that are tough
we're just working through it and it's a
lot of work my
one of my speakers teases me charis she
says oh barbara
i'm going to change your middle name to
iterate because i iterate everything i'm
like
wait that doesn't feel right but it's
true because
there is spirit to words and
we've got to feel them so if we don't
feel the words
the audience won't either and that's
what they need so
that's our job
you